[Music]
I think the thing that causes
relationships to become toxic our
many-fold I was started by saying
pessimism you know being around people
who are pessimistic about life is to me
one of the greatest obstacles that
stands in the way of greatness success
whether it's in the workspace whether
it's in your personal life
self-pity you know people who tend to
wallow in self-pity
are to me some of the most toxic
especially if you have close proximity
to them intimate relations or your
workspaces because that energy begins to
translate and it dims the room and it's
just really it's unsettling you know to
me I think it's one of the things that
we don't evaluate enough and our lives
are the people that we allow to share
our mental space and when you're
allowing somebody to share your mental
space you have to think of it like a
pristine house so you have this
beautiful home and you know when you
welcome people to your beautiful home
you will want them to treat it the way
that you treated and caring for it so
you wouldn't want them to walk in with
some muddy boots and you know just come
in and trashing the place but we don't
think about that when it comes to
welcoming people into the interior of
our minds and our hearts and so a lot of
times we'll have people in our lives who
wear those mental muddy boots and
they'll just come in and Trump a lot
around our mental space and we don't
even think nothing of it because we want
to be a nice person
and we don't want to say things that may
come across as mean but I think it's
important to recognize the people that
you welcomed into your life recognize
the quality the shared value systems and
realized when they're being hurtful were
damaging to your own sense of peace and
confidence and mental
being I think toxic relationships are
some of the most time-consuming
relationships you're constantly trying
to correct behavior you're constantly
assessing yourself based on those
relationships I mean I grew up in an
abusive household and the abuse that
probably had the biggest impact was the
things that was said to me and how I
replayed those things over and over in
my mind so you spent so much time in
your own head second-guessing yourself
doubting yourself
and you can't be as productive and as
successful as you're capable of as long
as you're allowing that energy to take
residence in your mind and it impacts
every aspect of your life you're not
showing up as a fourth self you can't be
happy you know and and even with the
idea of happiness I think that we are
delusional about what happiness is it's
not the sustained thing but it is it's
access to a part of ourselves that
allows us to have joy and so when you
think about what do you need in order to
have that has to be fulfillment and you
can't have fulfillment in your life in
your workspace as long as you have toxic
people occupying those spaces so I think
the way that you prevent a relationship
from becoming toxic is you have to set
real boundaries those boundary start
with what are the expectations what are
the rules of engagement what is
acceptable behavior what is acceptable
treatment and that starts with you
setting the standards for yourself you
know how do you show up in your own life
you know how do you treat yourself what
do you expect in yourself and that
extends out really and what I what I
found is that you know when you're when
you're dealing with people who are toxic
sometimes they don't even realize
they're toxic because they're just
repeating
per the cycle of you know hurt people
hurting people and you know and even
though toxic relationships don't show up
as necessarily intentional hurt it can
be intentional hindrance or
unintentional hindrance and so to me you
know you have to set those boundaries
very early and once once the
relationship has already become toxic
you have to make a choice in terms of
what do you value more do you value your
peace of mind and sense of purpose more
than you value the relationship and and
once you recognize what you value then
you have to share that with a person
that that may be toxic in your life and
what I found is that it is very hard for
people to in friendships it's very hard
for people to work in an environment and
not communicate or interact with a
co-worker even though that co-worker may
be toxic so it takes a certain level of
courage you know it takes a certain
level of value of who you are as a human
being to say you know what this isn't
working and we need to sit down we need
to talk about this and I believe in
confronting things head-on
you know if there's somebody who's toxic
in my life I'm very explicit that hey
here's what's happening and here what
does here's what doesn't work for me and
what are some steps we can take to
ensure that if we're going to interact
with each other that it's in the
healthiest way possible and if they're
not willing to step up to the plate to
accept the terms of the agreement then I
have to terminate that contract
[Music]
you